HER PODCAST, GREAT INTERVIEW,
SMART MAN.
GREAT JOB FILLING IN FOR TUCKER.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
FOR THE FULL HOUR, BY THE WAY,
OUR COVERAGE OF THE FBI'S
ALARMING RAID AND MAR-A-LAGO.
WE ARE GOING TO GO INTO SPECIFIC
DETAILS THAT A PROMISE YOU WON'T
GET FROM THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
WE WILL GO THROUGH IT SLOWLY,
CHECK IN WITH
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO.
PAUL MANAFORT, WHO WENT THROUGH
A PREDAWN RAID, GUNS DRAWN, NO
KNOCK, JOHN SULLIVAN, THE GREAT
ONE, MICHAEL BENNET WILL ALL
JOIN US LIVE TONIGHT.
HERE, MORE THAN 20 FARMERS HAVE
PASSED AND SCORES
OF HEAVILY ARMED FBI AGENTS
STORMED INTO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
PRIVATE HOME IN MAR-A-LAGO, FOR
A RAID.
THIS IS TOTALLY UNPRECEDENTED.
IT SHOULD BE DEEPLY, DEEPLY
CONCERNING TO EVERY AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
IT SHOULD TRANSCEND POLITICS.
NOT ONLY IS PRESIDENT TRUMP A
FORMER U.S. PRESIDENT, HE IS
ALSO BIDEN'S CHIEF POLITICAL
RIFLE.
SO NATURALLY, THE WHITE HOUSE IS
VERY SHORT TONIGHT ON ANSWERS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ON A GIVEN TOPIC, THE FBI HAS
A SEARCH WARRANT ON THE FORMER
PRESIDENT PUNCH OF AS A
RESIDENCE FLORIDA.
WAS THE PRESIDENT OR ANYONE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE AWARE OF THAT
WARRANT, OR HAS ANYONE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH THE PRESIDENT
BEEN BRIEFED IN THE AFTERMATH OF
THAT?
>> NO.
THE PRESIDENT WAS NOT BRIEF, WAS
NOT AWARE OF IT.
NO.
NO ONE AT THE WHITE HOUSE WAS
GIVEN A HEAD.
NO, THAT DID NOT HAPPEN.
>> Sean: LET ME BE EXTREMELY
CLEAR, SOMEONE WHO IS ONE OF THE
LETTER TO SUPPORTERS, IF YOU
WATCH THE SHOW OR LISTEN TO THIS
RADIO SHOW COME OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT ON TV AND RADIO
IN THE COUNTRY FOR DECADES,
AFTER YEARS OF WITCH HUNTS,
POLITICAL PERSECUTIONS, THE
RUSSIA HOAX, FRANKLY OUR
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, OUR FBI'S
REPUTATION IS ALREADY IN
TATTERS, ESPECIALLY WITH
ANYTHING RELATED TO
DONALD TRUMP.
ESPECIALLY THIS, THE FBI AND DOJ
THAT HAVE HAD HUNTER BIDEN'S
LAPTOP FOR YEARS.
A LAPTOP THAT IMPLICATES BOTH
HUNTER AND JOE BIDEN, THE BIG
GUY HIMSELF, IN NUMEROUS CRIMES
AND LIES AND THEY HAVE NOT
LIFTED A FINGER AT THE FBI OR
THE DOJ TO BRING JUSTICE TO THE
BIDEN FAMILY.
FRANKLY, UNFORTUNATELY I SAY
THIS, I NO LONGER BELIEVE THAT
IN THIS GREAT COUNTRY OF OURS
THAT WE HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
THE LAW, NOR DO I BELIEVE THAT
WE HAVE EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR
LAWS IN THIS COUNTRY.
IF YOUR LAST NAME IS CLINTON OR
BIDEN, YOU LIKELY GET A PASS.
IF YOUR LAST NAME IS TRUMP OR IF
YOU ARE AN ASSOCIATE OF ANYTHING
TRUMP, YOU GET THE HEAVY-HANDED
TACTICS OF PREDAWN RAIDS, GUNS
DRAWN, AND IN SOME CASES EVEN
FAKE NEWS CNN CAMERAS.
AGAIN, LET ME BE VERY CLEAR.
I ALWAYS USED TO SEND THIS
PROGRAM DURING THE RUSSIA HOAX,
99% RANK AND FILE COME FBI
AGENTS FOR THEIR LIVES AT RISK,
WORK HARD TO KEEP THIS COUNTRY
SAFE.
TONIGHT I SAY IT'S ABOUT 95%.
THERE ARE A LOT OF GOOD PEOPLE
IN THE FBI AND IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
THE FBI AND THE DOJ, THEY HAVE
SADLY EARNED THE COUNTRY'S
DISTRUST, ESPECIALLY THE UPPER
ECHELON, WHICH WE NOW KNOW HAS
BEEN AND CONTINUES TO REMAIN AT
ROTTEN THE CORE.
THIS RAID REEKS OF POLITICAL
BIAS AND INTIMIDATION, YET TOTAL
SILENCE FROM CHRISTOPHER WRAY AT
THE FBI, TOTAL SILENCE FOR
MERRICK GARLAND AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
APPARENTLY THE ANSWER TO NOBODY,
LEAST OF ALL YOU THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WHY WAS THIS RAID CONDUCTED?
AMERICANS DESERVE ANSWERS
TONIGHT.
EVEN MITCH McCONNELL IS ASKING
FOR THEM.
AND BY THE WAY, JIM JORDAN WANTS
ANSWERS ON FRIDAY.
DIRECTOR WRAY AND
MERRICK GARLAND OUGHT TO GO
BEFORE CONGRESS.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, THE FBI
WAS LOOKING FOR PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS REQUESTED BY THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES FROM TRUMP'S
TIME IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
CALL ME A SKEPTIC, I DON'T BUY
THAT FOR ONCE I COMPARE THIS
LIKELY DOES NOT HAVE MUCH IF NOT
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES.
YOU DON'T RAID THE PRESIDENT
MUCH OF HIS HOME BEFORE DAWN
WITH THOUSANDS OF AGENTS FOR A
FEW DOCUMENTS THAT MAY OR MAY
NOT BELONG TO THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES.
IN A STATEMENT FROM FEBRUARY,
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES SAID THEY
OBTAINED "FULL COOPERATION" WITH
TRUMPET OFFICIALS AND WERE
ALREADY WORKING WITH THEM TO
TRANSFER KEY DOCUMENTS.
THE FBI AGENTS ON THE SCENE
REPORTEDLY TOOK EVERY DOCUMENT
INSIGHT AT MAR-A-LAGO WITHOUT
EVEN BOTHERING TO READ ANY OF
THE MATERIAL.
AND ACCORDING TO ERIC TRUMP ON
THIS SHOW LAST NIGHT AND
NUMEROUS OTHER SERVICES THAT WE
HAVE ON THIS PROGRAM, THE FBI
REFUSED TO ALLOW THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTORNEYS TO WATCH WHAT THEY
TOOK.
WHY NOT?
AND IT GETS WORSE.
OF THE JUDGE WHO REPORTEDLY
SIGNED OFF ON THE WARRANT, VAGUE
OBAMA DONOR.
BY THE WAY, ONCE REPRESENTED
JEFFREY EPSTEIN'S EMPLOYEES AS
THEIR ATTORNEY.
I'M SURE HE'S A MAN OF GREAT
CHARACTER.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS WAS A FISHING
EXPEDITION IN SEARCH OF
SOMETHING, ANYTHING, NOW WE ARE
FINDING OUT THAT A TRUMP ALIA,
CONGRESSMAN SCOTT.
JUST HAD HIS PHONE SEIZED BY THE
FBI EARLIER TODAY.
AGAIN, NO EXPLANATION
WHATSOEVER.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THIS AND
JUST A MOMENT.
AFTER ALL, THE DOJ AND THE FBI
LIES AND ALL THEIR CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, THEIR THREE-YEAR LONG
PLUS HOAX, INCLUDING FBI
INSURANCE INSURANCE POLICY OF
PETER STRZOK.
THEY HAVE NOW LEARNED THE LOSS
OF TRUST FOR YOU, WE, WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE DEEP STATE SADLY IS ALIVE
AND WELL IN THIS COUNTRY AND WE
ARE NOW WITNESSING A DARK
NEW CHAPTER INTO THE PERSECUTION
OF DONALD TRUMP AND SADLY, THE
WEAPONIZATION OF OUR DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
NOW YOU MAY ASK, WHY WOULD
ANYONE AS A REPUBLICAN AND
CONSERVATIVE TRUST OF THE BIDEN
FBI IN THE BIDEN DOJ?
FIRST, THE SAME FBI, DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, SAME INSTITUTIONAL
PEOPLE, THEY TRY TO MAKE
A CONNECTION BETWEEN TRUMP TOWER
AND ALFA BANK, A MAJOR RUSSIA
INSTITUTIONAL, FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION, AND THAT THE
SERVERS WERE INSIDE OF
TRUMP TOWER.
IT WAS A BOGUS STORY, IT'S BEEN
TOTALLY DEBUNKED.
THEN THEY MOVED ONTO THE FAKE
CLAIMS OF A DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER.
THAT WAS THE COLLECTION OF
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION, BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON.
DONALD TRUMP'S OPPONENT IN 2016
AND THE DNC.
NONE OF THE CLAIMS AND THAT
DOSSIER WERE VERIFIED OR EVEN
VERIFIABLE.
AND THEY'VE BEEN DEBUNKED.
BUT THAT DIDN'T STOP THE FBI,
THE TOP ECHELON FROM USING THAT
PHONY MATERIAL NOT ONCE, NOT
TWICE, BUT FOUR TIMES AS
EVIDENCE, FOUR SEPARATE PHIS
APPLICATIONS AGAINST TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AD CARTER PAGE, THEY
USED THE WARRANT BY LYING TO THE
FISA COURT, EVEN WHEN THE SUB
SOURCE OF CHRISTOPHER STEELE
SAID NONE OF IT'S TRUE.
AND THEY USED IT TO BACKDOOR
INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN TO SPY
AND THEN SPY ON THEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEN THE TRUMP TRANSITION TEAM
AND THE TERM PRESIDENCY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THAT?
OF COURSE THE MEDIA MOB, THERE
ARE LIES, THEY LIED TO YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR THREE LONG
YEARS.
EVERYTHING THEY REPORTED HAS
BEEN VINDICATED.
THIS LED TO THE MUELLER PROBE
THAT LED TO NOTHING DESPITE A
LEGAL BARRAGE OF EVERYTHING
TRUMP WORLD.
PAUL MANAFORT, THE PREDAWN RAID,
GUNS POINTED IN HIS AND HIS
WIFE'S FACE, NUMEROUS FINANCIAL
CHARGES DATING BACK TO HIS TIME
AS A CONSULTANT.
HE SPENT WEEKS AND WEEKS AND
MONTHS IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT.
HE WAS PARADED AROUND IN
SHACKLES LIKE A SERIAL KILLER.
HE WILL JOIN US TONIGHT.
ROGER STONE, HE ENDURED A
PREDAWN RAID.
THE FBI EVEN PUT FBI -- IN THE
WATER BEHIND STONE'S HOUSE AND
SOMEONE INVITED CNN CAMERAS TO
FILM IT ALL AT 5:30 A.M.
MEANWHILE, AND YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED TO LIEUTENANT FLYNN?
HIS FAMILY WAS TREATED TO LEGAL
CHARGES BEFORE THAT AND FLYNN
WAS PURPOSELY MISLED BY YAP,
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY HIMSELF.
HE WANTED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE.
I SENT THEM.
PRIME'S ADMINISTRATION, THE
FIRST FEW DAYS
HE WAS IN OFFICE.
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS RAILROADED
WITH A PROCESS CRIME.
MORE RECENTLY, PETER NAVARRO
SHACKLED AT AN AIRPORT,
HUMILIATED PUBLICLY BECAUSE OF A
MISDEMEANOR?
USUALLY YOU TELL SOMEONE TO
REPORT AT THIS TIME OR WE WILL
SEND PEOPLE OUT AND EXECUTE A
WARRANT.
HILLARY CLINTON PUT AMERICA'S
NATIONAL SECURITY AT RISK,
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL STORED ON
HER PRIVATE SERVER.
WE HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE IN THIS
COUNTRY CUSTOMER AND SHE TRIED
TO COVER IT UP WE KNOW BY
DESTROYING
EVIDENCE, INCLUDING WIPING HARD.
IT IS SOMETHING WE NEVER KNEW OR
HEARD ABOUT BEFORE CALLED BLEACH
BIT.
SHE DESTROYED PHONES WITH
HAMMERS, RETURNED OTHER PHONES
WITHOUT THE SIM CARDS, MEANING
WITHOUT ANYTHING IN THEM.
SHE DELETED OVER 30,000 OFFICIAL
EMAILS AND AT THE HEIGHT OF THAT
INVESTIGATION INTO THESE EMAILS,
HILLARY'S HUSBAND BILL WAS
HAVING A STRANGE CONVERSATION
WITH OBAMA'S ATTORNEY GENERAL,
LORETTA LYNCH, DURING A PRIVATE
MEETING ON THE TARMAC OF AN
AIRPORT IN ARIZONA.
NATURALLY AFTER THE
STATE DEPARTMENT REPORT FOUND
500 VIOLATIONS FOUNDING THIS
PRIVATE SERVICE SCANDAL, HILLARY
WAS NEVER CHARGED WITH A CRIME
IN HER HOME WAS NEVER RATED.
HUNTER BIDEN DIDN'T HAVE TO FACE
ANY CHARGES ALSO BEAR THE
PRESIDENT'S SON WAS FILM SMOKING
CRACK ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS,
THAT IS AGAINST THE LAW.
AS A MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENCE THAT
HE FREQUENTLY HIRED PROSTITUTES.
AT THE SAME TIME, HUNTER RAKED
IN MILLIONS AND MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM FOREIGN
NATIONALS FOR NO OTHER REASON
OTHER THAN ACCESS TO HIS
FATHER'S POSITION AS
VICE PRESIDENT AND GOVERNMENT.
HE TOOK 4 MILLION FROM UKRAINIAN
OIL AND GAS GIANT OF MARIE'S MY.
HE TOOK THREE-POINT
$5 MILLION FROM THE FORMER FIRST
LADY OF MOSCOW.
HE TOOK PART OF A
MULTIBILLION-DOLLAR SWEETHEART
DEAL WITH THE BANK OF CHINA,
$1.5 MILLION.
HE HAD A $105,000 FAMILY
SHOPPING SPREE, COMPLIMENTS OF
COMMUNIST PARTY CHINESE
OFFICIAL.
WHERE'S THAT RACE?
ALL TOLD, JOE BIDEN IN SPITE OF
WHAT HE SAID PUBLICLY, HE MEANT
AT LEAST 14 OF HUNDREDS
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS PARTNERS.
I NEVER ONE TIME DISCUSSED WITH
MY SON ANY OF HIS FOREIGN
BUSINESS DEALINGS.
MANY OF THOSE WERE PHOTOGRAPHED
BUT FOR SOME REASON JOE DENIED
EVER DISCUSSING BUSINESS WITH
HUNTER.
HE LIED TO YOU THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND WE HAVE EVIDENCE OF
THAT LIFE.
BY THE WAY, IT'S ALL ON HUNTER'S
LAPTOP, WHICH IS NOT RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION, AND DIRECTOR
WRAY AND THE FBI HAVE HAD IT
LONGER THAN ANYBODY AND NOTHING
HAS HAPPENED.
PETER NAVARRO SHACKLED AT AN
AIRPORT FOR A MISDEMEANOR.
ROGER STONE GETS HIS HOUSE RATED
FOR PROCESS CRIME.
HUNTER BIDEN CAN APPARENTLY DO
ANYTHING HE WANTS AND HE WILL
GET AWAY WITH IT.
AND AS FOR THE NATIONAL ARCH ARE
RECORDS, HERE'S HOW YOU KNOW THE
RAID OF MAR-A-LAGO'S COMPLETE
AND TOTAL B.S.
ONE FORMER TOP AIDE FOR
BILL CLINTON NAMED SANDY BERGER,
REMEMBER SANDY THE BURGLAR?
HE TRIED TO ENDED STEAL
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL ABOUT 9/11
RIGHT FROM THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE WENT INTO THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES, FOUND THE
DOCUMENTS HE WAS LOOKING FOR,
SHOVE THEM DOWN HIS PANTS ON HIS
BACKSIDE INTO HIS SOCKS, AND
WALKED OUT.
AND SANDY BERGER WAS PUNISHED
WITH A MERE SLAP ON THE WRIST, A
MISDEMEANOR, FINE.
EVERYONE IN THE MEDIA MOB, THEY
SAID HE WAS BEING SLOPPY,
SLOPPY, SLOPPY.
HE DIDN'T MEAN TO TAKE THEM WHEN
HE THREW IT RIGHT DOWN HIS
CROTCH, HE HAD NO IDEA THAT WAS
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL THAT MADE
ITS WAY INTO HIS UNDERWEAR.
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES GET THE PREDAWN
RAID.
DOES ANY OF THIS SEEM NORMAL TO
YOU?
ON TOP OF THREE YEARS OF RUSSIA
CONSPIRACY, LIES, HOAXES,
MISINFORMATION, PROPAGANDA AND
AN ABUSE OF POWER AND CORRUPTION
LIKE WE'VE NEVER SEEN IN HISTORY
BEFORE.
ON TWITTER, HOUSE LEADER
McCARTHY TOLD MERRICK GARLAND
TO PRESERVE YOUR DOCUMENTS AND
CLEAR YOUR CALENDAR FOR AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
WEAPONIZATION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
FORMER GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS
COMPARE THE FBI'S ACTIONS TO
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS IN A
BANANA REPUBLIC.
VIRGINIA GOVERNOR YOUNGKIN SAID
THAT THESE KINDS OF POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED ACTIONS HAVE NO PLACE
IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
EVEN DEMOCRAT, FORMER GOVERNOR
OF NEW YORK ANDREW CUOMO
DECLARING THE DOJ MUST
IMMEDIATELY EXPLAIN THE REASON
FOR THIS RAID AND IT MUST BE
MORE THAN A SEARCH FOR
INCONSEQUENTIAL ARCHIVES OR IT
WILL BE VIEWED AS A POLITICAL
TACTIC AND UNDERMINE ANY FUTURE
CREDIBLE INVESTIGATION PEER THAT
CREDIBILITY TO ME HAS BEEN LONG
GONE.
CREDIBILITY OF THE FBI AND THE
DOJ WAS ALWAYS HANGING BY A
THREAD.